let's bring in Ben Shapiro he was able
to listen he's editor in chief of Daily
wired.com a syndicated syndicated
columnist and host of the Ben Shapiro
show so let me start with Al Franken if
the goal was to turn the tables on
President Trump and the Republicans did
Al Franken statement today do that yeah
I don't think Franken statement did that
because Franken basically walked out and
said I'm innocent but I'm leaving anyway
that allows everybody else to say I'm
innocent and I'm not leaving if Franken
really had any brains but he would have
done is he would he would have said you
know I've made some mistakes in my life
and now I'm gonna do penance for them
and I wish that the President of the
United States would do the same but he
didn't have the smarts to do that or the
or the lack of ego to do that so instead
he didn't even take one for the team
here he's just leaving and he's mad
about it
does resigning in this way mean like
Conyers did never really having to say
they're sorry for actual accusations
that they that are made against them
because Franken has said he's not
denying that these situations occurred
but he's saying that he's basically
being run out of town and he doesn't
think it's fair if others are not going
to be run out of town as well frankly
I'm not sure he's even gonna leave I
mean he says that he's gonna leave in a
few weeks but let's say that Roy Moore
is elected and then he's seated without
an ethics investigation and and then he
turns around Franken and says well
listen Moore's here you're gonna throw
me out they're gonna keep more and I
think that frankenz still trying to hold
that he is you know going to be the
example the Democrats used is the guy
they pushed out so Trump and more have
to go it's gonna be kind of weak
there is no political pain really though
for the Democrats in this because of
you're talking about just a Senate seat
Minnesota the governor there a governor
Dayton is likely to put up Tina Smith
she's the lieutenant governor another
Democrat when the Republicans said they
wouldn't see more that was actually more
politically courageous in my opinion
because that was saying we're gonna take
our chances here we'd like to have a
Republican there but we are not going to
want to see more and I and most of them
are standing by that position so two
things can be true ones it can be right
to boot people from office who have
engaged in incredibly alleged sexual
abuse and also this can be a political
hit and the fact is that that getting
rid of Frank and as you say does nothing
for the Democrats to hurt them I mean
they're going to replace Franken with
another Democrat Conyers leaving he'll
just be another member
his extended family I'm sure who ends up
in that congressional seat cuz it's the
fiefdom of Detroit so we're dealing with
it's it's so bizarre and none of them
are qualified I do like that his son and
his grandnephew are gonna get in a fight
I think it'll be like Richard the third
his son Zach you know in prison his
grandnephew in the Tower of London one
of the things amazing is the Republicans
who have actually stood and said listen
more can't be elected or I'm not gonna
go vote for more that's actually a
political sacrifice that they're making
Democrats have yet to make an actual
political sacrifice here let me have you
listen to senator Bernie Sanders who
said this on CBS this morning
we have a President of the United States
who acknowledged on a tape widely seen
all over this country that he assaulted
women so I would hope that maybe the
President of the United States might pay
attention to what's going on and also
think about resigning
so I serve Sanders was asked about this
in the briefing she basically said this
is in the rear view mirror for us the
president addressed it in the campaign
I've addressed it from here and they
moved on and she really didn't get
pressed on it but the Democrats I think
with all this coordination have decided
if we all band together then we can
force President Trump out IOC that
happening I don't think the president
was going to resign over allegations
that he himself does not even believe to
be true even right there credible and
that the fact is that this is not a
matter of we're gonna shame the
president into resigning this is a
matter of here's a political political
club for us to beat the president with
and then hopefully in 2020 we can say
that our house is clean but the
Republicans have not cleaned house made
people like more they have people like
Trump and we're gonna stand up for women
in a way that Republicans won't look
Bernie Sanders saying this stuff a week
ago he was saying that he thought that
Al Franken might just stay right so this
will what change nothing changed all
that happened is the RNC endorsed for a
more Trump endorsed for a more and
suddenly the entire Democratic Party
decided that Franken would be the
sacrificial lamb so they can grab the
moral high ground it seemed like Franken
knew that too and then he was irritated
about it I want to get to another
subject yesterday apparently in a
hearing
Donald Trump jr. asserted
attorney-client privilege because he in
a conversation you had with his father
Jonathan Karl of ABC News asked Sarah
Sanders about that let's take a listen
Donald Trump jr. refused
about his conversations with the
president's idea 25 privilege with the
president releases from any such
privilege allowed to speak to the
committee that's a question you would
have to ask his attorneys we believe
that his lawyers had a legitimate reason
and basis for not answering those
questions but that's something I would
direct you to his attorneys to address
more fully Matthew's me but we can you
explain to me how it could be
attorney-client either Donald Trump jr.
nor President Trump or attorneys again
and that's something that you would have
to talk with Don Jr's attorneys about
that's not something I'm gonna be able
to comment from here that's I have to
say I think Sarah Sanders answered that
absolutely correctly but what about the
issue the underlying issue the point
that it can you assert attorney-client
privilege if neither of the parties are
attorneys the answer is no I mean the
short answer is no this is this is
something that all lawyers know which is
why you don't have superfluous parties
on legal calls if you're talking to the
lawyer then it's privileged if it's you
and me and a hundred other people and
there happens to be a lawyer on the call
for one of us then it doesn't apply
unless the lawyer is the lawyer for both
I mean theoretically if the lawyer is
the lawyer for both Donald and Donald
Trump jr. then it's possible that it's
privileged but they'd have to make that
case and I think that's pretty weak case
all right Ben Shapiro thanks for being
on the show today thanks a lot